[Musica]
già devo cominciare in modo diverso
perché ho
sentito i discorsi fatti fino adesso le
presentazioni e c'è sentivo un filo che
le legava tutte la tua Poi mi sono
Adesso sono arrivato qui sopra ho capito
il filo è la vita la
vita e quindi per questo il titolo della
mia presentazione è il dono della vita
un dono il dono della felicità la
settimana scorsa il mio figlio più
piccolo
Romeo ha fatto il primo tema per
l'ingresso in prima media e doveva
parlare dei suoi sogni il primo sogno è
alzare la Coppa del Mondo di calcio da
capitano della Nazionale italiana e lui
ha detto che ci sta lavorando ed è vero
perché si allena duro gioca a calcio ha
fatto 25 gol l'anno scorso poi gli altri
due secondo me più abbordabili barman e
Dj l'ultimo poi siccome lo chiamava
Marcello il suo amico sotto casa una
chiosa veramente ruffiana ma il sogno
più bello è quello che tutte le persone
vorrebbero Cioè quello di essere sempre
felice giusto
geniale Quand'è che siamo felici siamo
felici quando riceviamo un
dono ma siamo felici anche quando il
dono lo facciamo perché ci gratifica
vediamo l'altra persona che che è felice
Ecco io nella mia carriera professionale
l'anno prossimo saranno 30 anni
cominciato da studente eh
quindi
e ho incontrato delle persone per il
quale il dono più grande era quello di
avere un figlio quindi avrete capito che
lavoro nella procreazione medicalmente
assistita in particolare Io sono un
embriologo l'embriologia
quella figura professionale che prende
lo spermatozoo lo mette dentro la
cellula uovo e poi fa crescere
l'embrione e questo
embrione può impiantare nell'utero della
paziente se viene
trasferito può dare origine alla
gravidanza può sviluppare un feto e poi
può dare origine a un bambino Uso il
condizionale perché so quanto è
complicata questa
cosa prima si è parlato di Nobel e lui è
il cavo è stato il nostro capo il capo
degli embriologi Robert Edwards è stato
il primo embriologo che ha ricevuto il
premio Nobel per la medicina per il suo
contributo che ha dato alla nascita di
Luis Brown negli Nel 1978 la prima
bambina DAT in provetta e nel primo Talk
abbiamo sentito parlare di donne che non
hanno ricevuto il Nobel si dice che
dietro il lavoro di di idws c'era
un'altra embriologa come Seo andate le
cose non lo so perché io non c'era in
quel momento so tanto che da quel
momento in poi l'embriologia è cresciuta
molto adesso sono decine di migliaia gli
embriologi che lavorano in tutto il
mondo e le competenze che dobbiamo avere
sono diverse e perché dobbiamo saper
fare la coltura cellulare ma conoscere
anche la biochimica e dobbiamo saper
fare la microm manipolazione ci vogliono
tanti anni di allenamento perché
lavoriamo con dei microm manipolatori
robotizzati e sottov visione
microscopica per prendere gli
spermatozoi che sono piccolissimi 5
Micron e metterli dentro la cellula uovo
e con gli stessi microm manipolatori
prendiamo quando l'embrione si forma una
decina di cellule e poi le
impacchettiamo eh congeliamo l'embrione
le impacchettiamo per poi dopo avere
informazioni genetiche su quell'
embrione quindi dobbiamo avere nozione
di biologia molecolare ma anche di
genetica Però anche di eh gestione di un
laboratorio qualità e gestione del
rischio eh counseling con i pazienti e
soprattutto di criobiologia
che diciamo che è la cosa Il settore che
è più cresciuto all'interno della
medicina della riproduzione negli ultimi
15 anni negli ultimi quando io ho
cominciato a fare questo lavoro e
sopravvivevano quando andavamo a
congelare gli spermatozoi sopravvivevano
con una buona efficienza perché gli
spermatozoi sono cellule che hanno poca
acqua e sono molto resistenti quando
andavamo a congelare gli embrioni
soltanto la metà allo scongelamento
sopravvivevano e diciamo resuscitano
adesso faccio vedere questo che è un
manifesto
eh abbiamo ottimizzato una eh tecnica e
che si chiama vitrificazione che era
nota Fin dagli anni 40 ai primi
criobiologia e che è la stessa principio
fisico non abbiamo più il fisico no
che serve per fare il vetro eh Cioè è la
passaggio dalla fase liquida a quella
solida senza la formazione di cristalli
ordinati perché questi cristalli nelle
cellule romperebbero solitamente sono
cristalli di acqua perché le cellule
sono ricche d'acqua romperebbero le
strutture cellulari e
quindi non permettono una buona
sopravvivenza delle cellule
Ecco questo è stato un manifesto cioè la
position Paper position Paper della
società americana di fertilità che
toglie l'etichetta sperimentale sul
congelamento degli ovociti gli ovociti
sono le cellule più fragili perché sono
più grandi del nell'organismo umano sono
quelle più ricche d'acqua quindi nel
momento in cui noi siamo riusciti ad ad
ottimizzare ad congelare gli ovociti con
una buona
eh efficienza lì abbiamo avuto la svolta
Ma la cosa interessante che su questo
position Paper il 30% degli articoli
citati in
bibliografia sono scritti da embriologi
italiani
io ritengo che sia una cosa molto
importante io adesso vi voglio dire
perché è importante perché adesso nel
70% dei casi nei nostri laboratori
lavoriamo con cellule
congelate quando dobbiamo trattare una
coppia ci troviamo davanti a diverse
situazioni nella prima situazione quella
più comune utilizziamo lo spermatozoo
del partner maschile e l'ovocita della
partner femminile ma ci sono delle
situazioni Ecco la linea sottile in cui
questi queste cellule non sono di buona
qualità in cui lo spermatozoo non
funziona bene il l'ovocita non funziona
bene o non ci sono perché si sono
inariditi gli organi che servono a
generare queste cellule quindi
interviene un donatore esterno un
donatore volontario e anonimo che dona
una sua cellula è lo stesso meccanismo
che conosciamo nel caso di una donazione
di organo
Eh ma ovviamente è un po' Meno
complicato perché diciamo abbastanza
sconveniente donare un organo perché
siamo deceduti nella maggior parte dei
casi invece in questo caso si fa come in
altre situazioni magari come per il
midollo si fa ancora da vivi bital anche
Anzi da da giovani
e ed è molto più semplice perché
comunque in ogni caso nel momento che
generiamo l' embrione non ci sono rischi
di rigetto è una tecnica che funziona
molto bene
il problema qual è È che in
Italia nessuno racconta ai ragazzi che
possono donare gli spermatozoi uciti
qualche anno fa con il mio gruppo
abbiamo fatto questo articolo nel quale
raccontavamo come una metà dei
trattamenti che facevamo a quel
tempo per una metà utilizzavamo
spermatozoi donati da donatori italiani
mentre per gli ovociti nella maggior
parte parte dei casi dovevamo ricorrere
a donatori esteri cioè come funziona in
altre nazioni dove la donazione è più
promossa di cui si
parla Le gli istituti di tessuti e le
cliniche gli ospedali hanno donatori che
possono servire i pazienti che
afferiscono a quelle cliniche e e ma
anche hanno un surplus e quindi lo
possono dare alle cliniche che lavorano
in altre
nazioni in Italia fare la donazione è
complicato sono delle mosche bianche
quelle che arrivano nei nostri centri e
ci chiedono di donare e per esempio le
mie colleghe i miei colleghi sanno che
quando ci contatta un ragazzo una
ragazza che vuole donare Io ci voglio
parlare subito perché voglio capire qual
è la motivazione da dove hanno sentito
che potevano donare Magari hanno avuto
una situazione di questo tipo a casa e
quindi la conoscevano oppure venivano
hanno vissuto all'estero e quindi per
loro era una cosa normale
eh in realtà Allora quello di cui voglio
parlare oggi e di cui vorrei contribuire
a togliere l'etichetta così come ha
avuto la fortuna di farlo per
l'etichetta sperimentale nel
congelamento degli ovociti è lo stigma
Riguardo a questa procedura alla
donazione di cellule riproduttive di cui
nessuno parla I
donatori gli operatori del settore i
pazienti le strutture che fanno questa
attività hanno questo marchio Ok
ma
se
consideriamo un fuoco
e nel fuoco abbiamo il la legna che è il
combustibile e l'ossigeno che che
comburente quindi ci troviamo in una
situazione in cui non ci manca il
combustibile
ipoteticamente abbiamo giovani ragazzi
che potrebbero donare semplicemente ci
manca il comburente l'ossigeno ci manca
la
comunicazione relativamente al fatto che
questa donazione può essere fatta per
esempio se googlei e andiamo a cercare
donazione di
organi al primo posto Ci viene
l'associazione per la donazione
promozione della donazione degli organi
che è l'aido se googlei donazione di
midollo ci viene fuori l'associazione
per la donazione di midollo che è l'adm
se googlei am D donazione di sangue ci
viene fuori Avis cete tutti eh mi ha
detto che ha fatto una campagna con con
l'Avis se googlei donazione di cellule
riproduttive di spermatozoidi
ociti niente il deserto Eppure io mi
ricordo che vi ho detto che 30 anni che
faccio questo lavoro che qualche anno fa
qualcuno aveva provato a fare
un'associazione
per promuovere la donazione io stesso
però non me la ricordo quindi qualche
problema Ci deve essere perché
io lavoro in un gruppo che abbiamo 20
cliniche e che dentro queste 20 cliniche
78 cliniche in varie nazioni nel mondo
fanno questo servizio di donazione io
sarei anche a posto Ok non è che però
pensiamo che in Italia anche gli
ospedali offrono Questo tipo di servizio
e gli ospedali lo offrono gratuitamente
è
L'unica nazione al mondo che offre
gratuitamente anche i trattamenti con
l'ovo donazione però hanno un cosa
importante per la sanità pubblica visto
che poi questi servizi devono essere
presi da cliniche estere e
queste questa movimentazione è tracciata
e regolamentata
egregiamente dal centro nazionale
trapianti per il Ministero della Salute
il centro nazionale trapianti fa un
grande lavoro
e si
occupa di seguire
e tutta la movimentazione delle delle
cellule che vengono dall'estero per fare
questo tipo di trattamento la cosa che
AB ha sorpreso però è che il mese scorso
il centro nazionale
trapianti fa uscire questo dossier
bellissimo che parla di costruire la
cultura del dono eh raccomandazioni in
tema di
comunicazione sul trapianto di organi
tessuti e
cellule Finalmente sono andato a cercare
ho detto mamma mia metto gli perché e
non parlava di spermatozoi ovociti ho
usato quindi il tool per leggere sui
PDF spermatozo OC non c'erano c'era
scritto cellule riproduttive detto
cellule riproduttive cellule
riproduttive c'è scritto in un paragraf
detto il CNT si occupa
della donazione tracciabilità e
trapianto di cellule riproduttive basta
per il midollo per eh
gli organi c'è scritto come fare una
donazione Come iscriversi alle liste
Come ricevere le le cellule gli organi e
tessuti Donati per le cellule
riproduttive non c'è scritto niente è
evidentemente disturbante parlare di
questa cosa Quindi cominciamo qui con
gentilezza senza fare una guerra Perché
e la mia
idea di combattere questo Stigma Beh non
dobbiamo usare parole di di guerra
parlare soffiare su quella fiammella che
ancora magari potrebbe essere rimasta e
alimentarla fare da comburente ai nostri
giovani donatori quindi
E perché Perché il dono è un atto
gentile il dono è avere
cura scegliamo di donare è una
possibilità di di connessione eh pensate
che bella connessione tra chi Dona E chi
riceve ed è motore di cambiamento Quindi
stasera cominciamo a
cambiare
[Musica]
Grazie